hey guys how's it going Merry Christmas
today I like to save my well I guess the
most difficult baking videos for the
actual holiday for Halloween I mean if
it's really cool gravestone cake so I
thought for Christmas I'm gonna try I'm
gonna bust out some of my fondant skills
I wanted to make a peppermint cake now
here's some inspiration there's this
little one they've got like little
gingerbreads on it and some stuff and
then this is like some peppermint so
basically what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
bind both of these cakes I don't really
know what's gonna happen - as you guys
know nobody ever knows what to expect in
this kitchen maybe it'll all work out
great maybe it won't I'm going to try my
best i pre-made the cakes because you
guys have seen me make cakes before like
we all know what what goes into that
actually Jenna made these games I can't
even say that I made them we look two
cakes so for this you're gonna want to
make one basic white cake I mean
honestly this is a box cake so we just
kind of dump this into the mixer did
what you do to make a cake and then
Jenna put so much red food coloring in
this we use gel food coloring and then
we use some other red food coloring
because it was not turning red basically
one of things if you have an allergy to
red dye do not eat this because you will
die and actually I don't think anyone
should eat this cuz there's a really
great chance that you're not gonna be
with us any longer first things first
oh I need my cake pan me my cake mat
okay we've got that so okay
no wait this is all wrong I've gotta
prep my icing first oh gosh so we're
gonna do is I learned this little trick
from my friend man about cake he taught
me that some of this pre-made icing that
you get all you got to do is dump it in
here add some butter and then it'll make
it much easier to spread so we're also
gonna do is I'm gonna add a little bit
of peppermint extract to it so it'll be
a nice peppermint flavor
it's just expired I can't find an
expiration date so let's just hope for
the best
we've got our spatula okay
when I flip it like 14 times in the air
but yet when I'm holding it like a
normal person this is the life that we
live blessed I'm not really sure how
much peppermint next driver like for me
I you can never have enough peppermint
heavenly okay let's just dump some of
this in every time I do these cooking
videos at the end of the day I've got
the booyah stomachache because I want to
eat every
that I'm making I got the boots with the
fur the whole club's looking at Hershey
I'm so used to not ever having the
butter be soft I left this out overnight
no look at it i'm bari take a sweater
off because i'm sweating so that's going
we're gonna that smells so good i wish
you guys could smell it it smells like
freakin Santa Claus Lane
[Applause]
[Laughter]
can you see it it's burning my skin is
burning my skin can you see oh shoot Oh
God my face okay oh my face is still
burning but I'm not sure what to do
about it like it kind of feels like I'm
getting like a chemical peel or
something I have never had one before
but I imagine this is what it feels like
and it's not a good feel done enough
because I think I stopped caring
once there's pain involved that's what
I'm like it's time to stop oh my face is
still burning
it feels so minty like just the picture
and imagine you put in a piece of bum
and your mouth feels minty those what my
face feels like I'm so uncomfortable
sweater is constricting on my body my
pants are too tight
I need my skin all right we've got a
cake and I'm so upset because normally
when I do this I'm able to really do a
great job of evenly cutting these cakes
but I can't find my cake leveler so I'm
not sure what to do I'm gonna have to do
it by hand so let's just hope for the
best thank you so far I'm doing a pretty
good job leveling this was gonna be a
four layer cake but uh I'm not sure if
I'm gonna be able to cut this in half
again so this is gonna be our nice
little you know I think to hold together
I got these I saw them on Amazon I was
like yeah I'll get them they are
peppermint I guess little chips so I'm
gonna sprinkle those in the middle and
hopefully nobody cracks a tooth when
they're expecting like a nice soft cake
I guess it's post Malone but say candy
flakes with the peppermint on top candy
Thurman hunts out oh god I gotta stop oh
my god this smells like what my face
feels like oh my god I'm having such a
Merry Christmas since this is no longer
gonna be four layer cake we can just
plop it right on I probably put my
headband back on this will help me focus
[Music]
SoDo put this in the fridge I think the
icing looks pretty good I may put
another coat of icing depending upon if
I feel lazy or not but if you do this I
would recommend putting another layer I
might skip that books in the fridge get
it - oh I don't have room in here what
am I thinking
Oh have some vegetables why would I put
vegetables when I get up cake this is
the best well Matt ever thank you a man
about cake I basically Oh anything good
that I do in my kitchen to him in row
because they're just the best
I just thought visit the new toy it's a
fondant roller I mean would you guys
even imagine like not long ago I didn't
even know how to use fondant and now I'm
a fondant roller Who am I you've got two
colors we've got a nice lights and we've
got a nice red and now we're gonna roll
out
Alexa play roll out
[Music]
[Applause]
red fondant no water lob jokes from here
on in I promise
actually I can't promise I'd sentido
roll this out big enough to cover the
entire cake and I'm concerned because
the last time I did this I almost went
into cardiac arrest being so out of
shape that rolling out this fondant I
was exhausted all right this is big
enough and if it's not at this point I
don't care because it's I'm tired okay
get ready for this are you ready for the
flip because I don't know what's gonna
happen
Oh actually this is not that bad I think
this is hopefully gonna be big enough
it's not yeah it's okay it's okay
because I'm covering the bottom anyway
hey it's like I love hate like I really
have fun doing this and then I and then
I do things like this and I get very
upset this is supposed to be real smooth
so supposed to be smooth and beautiful
this is the point where my expectations
were super high and now the expectations
I have none everything that I thought I
was gonna do feeling I'm not doing
anymore we're gonna add some decorations
to it I also have some lights they're
obviously not edible so don't be silly
[Music]
it goes supposed to meet goals it's
supposed to be a Christmas cake cookie I
think I'm gonna swap this out for this
little guy
we'll put you on when I dented it so I'm
gonna be straight so since I dropped
this uh it's not sanitary and it's
probably not gonna be straight Wow
that's so cool you big guy you're
supposed to like put stuff on here to
make this stick but I've stopped caring
so we're gonna just do basically all I
care about is this one section okay
that's all we need it doesn't matter
this isn't gonna stick on here because I
didn't put anything on it to make it
stick so why would it stick that doesn't
even look straight I guess I'll just put
them over top I'm not worrying about
this backside this doesn't exist in my
world shove that in there seems to be
something that I had really high hopes
for I had a lot of dreams when in doubt
just buy premade deck stuff from Wilton
and call it a day
this looks like something out of Mario
Odyssey like one of the things that you
like jumps around like one of the I
think was like a I forget what it was
even was it looks like something from
the game I lose all holes in one ho
equal oh ho ho
put a little Christmas tree right here
very honestly I'm so upset okay I swear
to you this I had all intentions of
making it was beautiful no just looks
like trash I wanted to make all custom
fondant creations on this it's okay you
got it you gotta make do with what you
got and this is what I've got right now
Merry Christmas
these are silvering I got them at Target
I went to the store the other day like
actual store I usually buy everything
online and I couldn't believe it
there's a lot of stuff at the analog
store these are incredible this
workspace has been contaminated so we're
gonna put this around the cave since I
don't care about the back I'm just gonna
put the battery pack back there you wrap
this around my little cake
oh but this is the coolest cake
ever actually I mean these Christmas
lights definitely elevated it I haven't
seen stranger things but I feel like
this is don't they have like lights or
something that you can talk to another
world or another dimension I'm not sure
[Music]
well I hope you guys enjoy that slow-mo
montage I shorted did you I didn't eat
yet but I'm sure I did look at different
color hat oh my goodness oh god I've got
a nice puppy
Wow hold it on this is their icing on
the inside oh wait till you see what's
on the inside oh well I made that cake
nice okay here you go here's your slice
eat up
it looks like it says hi Christy like
this little guy flick good race should
we take a bite you take one first cuz I
made it I'm worried is this peppermint
icing mm-hmm don't engage cause it's out
of it it doesn't taste good I don't know
what it tastes like chemicals what
bothers doesn't it I mean it's good
you're delirious no it's not bad I I
just feel like there's so much red dye
in that top cake it looks so lovely
okay lovely I'll take it up you guys
have a great Christmas Happy Holidays
whatever it is did you celebrate I hope
that you were enjoying it another break
cake
stop it I don't like that I don't
like that at all I've lost my mind this
took way too long to do I'll see you
later
[Music]